A racy conversation between Tormund and Brienne,
Cersei in a blood-soaked bed, and Jon's farewell
to Ghost were all chopped from season seven
of Game of Thrones.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm looking at some of the best
scenes that ended up cut from the seventh
season of HBO's mega-popular fantasy series.
By the way, my Game of Thrones Funko Pop giveaway
is also running on this video, so for a chance
to win: make sure you're subscribed to my
channel and leave a comment with your thoughts
about the deleted scenes or the show.
And quick warning: I'm talking spoilers for
all seasons and speculation for season 8.
The fearsome wildling leader Tormund Giantsbane
is one of my favourite characters on the show
and he's had some fantastic moments that bring
a lot of humour to the series.
And ever since season six, when he first laid
eyes on the mighty warrior Brienne of Tarth,
the formidable Tormund has been struck down
with puppy love.
There have been some hilarious scenes of Tormund
eyeing up Brienne and so far she's ignored
his advances, but fans of the pair may be
sad to know that some lines of rather racy
dialogue between the two were cut from this
season's very first episode.
The lost moment took place after Tormund approached
Brienne in Winterfell as she was sparring
with Podrick.
The red-haired wildling was going to try flirting
with Brienne by telling her about his experience
with Sheila the Bear.
You can see a little clip still in the episode
where Brienne walks off in disgust while Sansa
and Littlefinger are talking overhead.
Sadly, though, Tormund and Brienne's actual
conversation was cut.
This would have been a funny call-back to
season four when Tormund tried to impress
his fellow wildlings with his story claiming
he'd had carnal relations with a bear.
"Oh that was a night to remember."
"Her fangs were sharp, but she knew how to
use them."
"And she was nice and soft down beIow."
"No, she was no ordinary beast."
Ygritte was having none of Tormund's tall
tale back then and, clearly, Brienne wasn't
impressed by it either, or as the actor who
plays Tormund says, "she didn't like [his]
pick-up line" – which is hardly surprising
for all sorts of reasons including her own
experience having to fight a bear when she
was captured by Bolton men back in season
3.
In fact, Brienne's pretty uncomfortable with
the whole Tormund situation, which was made
clear in a deleted scene from season 6 that
showed Sansa teasing her about Tormund's interest
which sent the great warrior into a fluster
of embarrassment.
Still, I do hope Tormund and Brienne survive
at least a good few episodes next season so
we can see their paths cross again.
By the way, Tormund's attempted flirtation
with Brienne at Winterfell wasn't the only
moment featuring the wildling talking about
bears that ended up cut this season.
In episode 6, when a giant undead polar bear
appeared out of nowhere to attack Jon Snow's
ranging party, the first words out of Tormund's
mouth were, 'I've danced with plenty of bears',
though that line sadly hit the editing room
floor.
And the premiere episode also cut down another
scene, this time with Sam and Gilly.
It's during the scene where Sam is studying
books from the Citadel's restricted library
and remembers about the mountain of dragonglass
sitting beneath Dragonstone.
In that scene, Gilly picked up a book called
"Legends of the Long Night" and started to
read.
Unfortunately, the part where Gilly reads
aloud from the book was reportedly cut out,
so we missed out on hearing some very interesting
lines, including the following: "The white
cold rose up, and the Walkers rose with it.
And the sun hid its face for a lifetime, ashamed
at something none could discover".
In the cut scene, Gilly claims she knows what
made the sun do that and tells Sam that Craster
was drunk once when the time came to give
one of his baby boys away and he told the
child, "Come on, time to meet your brothers".
Gilly also reveals that some of Craster's
older wives referred to the White Walkers
as "Craster's Sons".
Gilly then thinks back to the time when a
White Walker attacked her, Sam and her baby
and questions whether he was one of her brothers.
Now, I wonder whether this scene was cut because
the audience already knows about Craster's
sons being turned into White Walkers, which
we saw in season four.
However, it's not clear whether any living
character on the show really knows this, though
Jon Snow did catch a glimpse of one of Craster's
sons being taken in season 2.
Maybe Gilly's reveal will be included next
season instead, especially if it makes a difference
to how the living can defeat the army of the
dead.
But it's a shame that Gilly's lines were cut
this season as they would have made her role
a bit more meaningful and they would also
have highlighted her part in uncovering important
information, even if by chance, like she did
in episode 5 with Rhaegar's annulment of his
marriage to Elia Martell.
And while we're on the subject of scenes with
Sam, the first episode showed a humorous montage
of what life was like for the budding maester
after he arrived at the Citadel.
And although it felt plenty long enough as
it was, there's actually an edit of the scene
which is seven to eight minutes long which
the episode director has described as "hilarious".
So, perhaps we'll see that as a Blu-ray extra?
We finally got to see Arya briefly reunite
with her long-lost direwolf Nymeria this season,
but our other favourite direwolf Ghost was
sadly chopped from his only scene which was
planned for episode two.
According to the season 7 outline, there was
a short scene where Ghost saw Jon off from
Winterfell as he left for Dragonstone.
In the cut scene, Jon told his direwolf, "Look
after anyone named Stark, boy!", which feels
like a touch of irony from the writers given
the full reveal of Jon's true heritage later
in the season.
It's a shame Ghost was, erm, ghosted this
season, but the reason was probably financial.
Game of Thrones' budget for special effects
will have already been stretched with the
need for a lot more dragon and White Walker
action, and, apparently, direwolves are more
expensive to animate than CGI dragons.
I suspect also a decision was made that we
should see Nymeria instead as she hasn't been
seen since Arya had to leave her in the woods
in season one, and their reunion underlined
just how much has changed for each of them
since then.
In fact, this is not the first time that Ghost
has had his screentime cut down as a scene
was deleted from season six where Ghost menaced
Alliser Thorne and other Night's Watchmen.
And according to the director of Battle of
the Bastards, Ghost was going to have a big
part in that episode, but it was just too
expensive, and when they had to choose between
Wun-Wun and the direwolf, they picked the
mighty giant instead.
One character who brings some humour to most
scenes he's in is Bronn, so it was a shame
that the scene of him and Tyrion having a
little reunion that was originally intended
to be in the fifth episode was dropped from
filming.
It looks like it would have occurred just
before Jamie arrives at the secret meeting
with Tyrion that Bronn helped set up in King's
Landing.
Of course, we did finally see the two men
back together on screen in the season finale,
though given how much fun the scenes they
share together often are, it would have been
great to see more of them.
Littlefinger's death was a long time coming
in Game of Thrones and it took seven seasons
of his scheming to finally come crashing down
on him before the Starks realised that he
was the one who'd set everything in motion.
Sansa even admitted she was a slow learner
in the final episode after still getting played
by Littlefinger throughout much of season
7.
In fact, there's a deleted scene where Sansa
goes to Bran to ask him for his help before
she executes her own sister Arya.
Actor Isaac Hempstead Wright, who plays Bran,
revealed in an interview with Variety that,
"it suddenly occurred to Sansa that she had
a huge CCTV department at her discretion and
it might be a good idea to check with him
first before she guts her own sister.
So, she goes to Bran, and Bran tells her everything
she needs to know."
According to Hempstead Wright, they did actually
film this scene, but I can see a couple of
possibilities for why it got the chop.
On the one hand, if it had been included,
it would have taken away from the drama of
the scene where Sansa calls Arya in and it
looks like she's about to sentence Arya to
death, but then she turns the tables on Littlefinger.
Also, the deleted scene further highlights
Sansa's ongoing naivety given the fact she
was still getting manipulated by Littlefinger
and ultimately needed Bran's help to figure
out what was really going on.
The season finale set up numerous storylines
to propel us into Season 8, but there is one
crucial scene detailed in the episode outline
which didn't make it into the final episode.
The cut scene would have occurred just after
Jaime stormed off from King's Landing in disgust
following Cersei's refusal to honour her agreement
to send the Lannister army north against the
Night King.
The scene is set at the Red Keep in King's
Landing and has Cersei waking up suddenly
in the middle of the night to discover her
bedclothes covered in blood.
This scene, which implies Cersei has just
miscarried, would have made a big difference
to how season 7 ended, and it feels like it
would also have had strong parallels with
the scene we saw in the finale of Lyanna Stark
lying in a bloody bed having just given birth.
As season 7 left Cersei still apparently pregnant
though, her future baby has already given
rise to a number of fan theories.
One such theory is that Tyrion has made a
deal with Cersei behind Dany's back to arrange
for Cersei's new child to inherit the Iron
Throne after Daenerys.
We know that Tyrion was concerned about the
succession and Dany's apparent inability to
have children, but what we don't know is if
he had to agree to something in order to change
Cersei's mind and make her publically support
Dany and Jon.
And Tyrion didn't look very happy when Dany
and Jon were hooking up at the end of the
episode, likely because of the political problems
their romantic relationship could cause; but,
if that Cersei fan theory is correct, Tyrion
could also be worried that if Dany does conceive
her own child it would scupper his deal with
his sister.
In any case, I do wonder whether this cut
scene has been moved to season 8, meaning
that we might still see Cersei miscarry.
Indeed, her miscarriage may be foreshadowed
in Jamie's words that, "Our child will never
be born if the dead come south".
Of course, Jaime was thinking of the Night
King's undead army, but technically the undead
have already come south in the form of the
wight that Jon and Dany brought to the Dragonpit.
I think the way the wight clawed at Cersei
after it came dangerously close to her could
also be some ominous foreshadowing for Cersei
and her baby.
For example, Cersei could die either through
miscarriage or in childbirth, which could
fulfil the valonqar prophecy that I talked
about in detail in my video predicting who
will die in Season 8.
Alternately, it's possible that the showrunners
have decided to go the route of Cersei lying
about being pregnant, so the scene could have
been cut for that reason.
So, what do you think about the season 7 deleted
scenes and do you think any of them should
have been included?
Also what were you best and worst moments
of this season?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and also don't forget to subscribe for
your chance to win an awesome Game of Thrones
Funko Pop.
The winner of my last giveaway for a Defenders
or Punisher Funko Pop is on screen right now.
If that's you, then send me a message with
your details so I can send you the prize.
If you enjoyed this, hit that thumbs-up button
and also check out my predictions on which
characters are mostly likely to die in the
final season of Game of Thrones.
Or you can watch more of my deleted scenes
videos by tapping the screen right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!